honestly this past fall i wasn't feeling
super inspired to create much of
anything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you to betterhelp for sponsoring
this video one thing about living on the
road full time is that there's so much
time to think and i'm constantly facing
new challenges that force me to grow as
a person
i recently started using better health
for online therapy as a way of better
understanding myself and this path that
i'm on and it's been an amazing
experience so far betterhelp will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist and you
can start communicating within 48 hours
via phone or video chat it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online the service is available
worldwide financial aid is available and
if you click my link in the description
below you'll get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com christian that's
better h-e-l-p
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh so since heading south uh there's
been a lot more sunshine in my life and
it's made living on the road a lot
easier um especially compared to the pnw
where it was pretty
wet rainy and dark it's also created
space for a few other things in my life
so i've been dedicating a lot of time to
reading journaling meditating and just
kind of doing some inner work
and
honestly this past fall i wasn't feeling
super inspired to create much of
anything i don't know why exactly maybe
you know when i think about it it could
just be that i felt pressure to
do all the things um like social media
platforms there's instagram there's
twitter there's youtube there's my
website there's actual work for
photography clients and commercial work
and sometimes it just starts to feel a
little overwhelming but at the same time
i'm realizing that obviously i don't
need to do all those things and
i just need to pick what i'm passionate
about and focus on that so
this place being in the white sands has
honestly
just reignited my inspiration and i have
been taking personal photos for the
first time in a long time
recently i would say that i've mostly
just been doing photography if it's um
for a commercial client so
it's been cool to
be really excited to start creating
again in that realm i'm also kind of
getting into nfts i haven't actually
released any yet but i'm super inspired
by the nft community over on twitter and
yeah i'm going to be putting together
a collection and probably in the next
coming months and i'll let you guys know
if any of you out there into nfts i'm
super excited about that and of course
video like
video i don't know it's just
there's something about
telling a story and piecing together all
these little
elements of travel and emotion and
beautiful landscapes that i just love
that you know photography can't
necessarily do or i mean it can but i
i don't know just find so much joy in
putting together videos so it means a
lot to me that you guys are here and
that you support my channel and yeah
i don't know i'm just really excited to
be here i freaking love it here it is so
beautiful
so
i think i'm getting sunburned so i'm
gonna head back
[Music]
do
[Music]
i've always wanted to explore new mexico
i've driven through plenty of times but
until recently the only stops i'd ever
made were at gas stations along the
interstate which by the way gas prices
here are the cheapest i've seen all year
i spent a few days in arizona along the
way it's nearly impossible to skip over
that beautiful state
but it wasn't long before i was finally
driving into the windswept dunes of
white sands national park
[Music]
do
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is easily one of the coolest places
i've ever been
[Music]
are you going to be late
i think so
we have to be out of the park by
6 p.m i don't know if we're gonna make
it
but we're gonna try
i guess we have to
we've been running
how far do you think
i don't know a mile a mile
we're exhausted and we have all of our
camera gear with us
we have officially
been running slash walking
for so long
and we're using a map so we know we're
not lost
but uh apparently we walked really far
we made it
we are one minute late hopefully they'll
forgive us there's still other cars in
the parking lot so
that was so much fun and such a workout
we found a great campsite near the park
and stayed for a while we spent our
mornings and afternoons working on a few
different client projects and our
evenings exploring the dunes are you a
butterfly
[Music]
good morning
they just made coffee
and
it's really cold outside
i think it was 24 degrees when i woke up
but with the heater on it's pretty nice
and i'm gonna go on a morning walk
[Music]
always
[Music]
we were down by the river all through
the night
watching the stars and the city lights
right from the start said we never grow
apart
[Music]
watching all the love has fallen
[Music]
glass towers rise
with shadows all around us
[Music]
the curses that become us
but you can't deny
the catch
of
[Music]
an open door but i could never leave
this violence sure
i could never leave
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this work look at that
[Music]
uh
[Music]